[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to with Marvel phase
three soon coming to an end
fans of the MCU are hotly anticipating
the next wave of the franchise this
includes Black Panther 2 which after the
first film is looking set to smash all
kind of box office and critical records
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the news that Michael B Jordan is set to
return as kill monger as well as giving
my opinion on how the franchise may do
this this is full spoilers ahead so if
you're one of the 10 people that haven't
seen Black Panther and don't know kill
mongers fate yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
black panther 2 casting news lover hate
him you have to admit that kill manga
was probably the biggest talking point
of 2018 s Black Panther Michael B Jordan
who played the character even went on to
win Best Villain at the MTV Movie Awards
becoming the only person to actually
beat Dallas that year however in the
finale of the film the character was
killed off after he was bested by the
titular character but that doesn't mean
that he's out of the running just yet
according to Roger Waddell who
successfully depending on how you look
at it leaked endgame to the masses as
stated that B Jordan will be returning
to the film this has been backed up by
Angela Bassett who played Romande at the
Screen Actors Guild Awards when asked if
everyone was set to return to the film
Bassett stated I would assume so which
was backed up by her husband Courtney B
bands who said yes just go ahead and say
it
yes everyone will be there just yes yes
when asked to clarify if this meant kill
monger Bassett stated we didn't
technically see him go into the ocean
no with fans following up and saying
including Michael B Jordan
so it looks like Mykleby is pretty much
set to make a big return to the movie
however I actually don't think that the
character will be alive kill manga was
so adamant that he would rather die at
the end of the film that have pretty
much confirmed his fate for me so how
else could the character return well
whilst his reign was short-lived
kill manga was still king of Wakanda and
therefore he will be present in the
spiritual plane alongside the rest of
the rulers of the nation thus it's a
pretty safe bet to assume that he will
appear here perhaps casting doubt into
Jerez mind over which course of action
to take I can definitely see this being
the case and I think would make for an
awesome scene in the film obviously I
love to hear your thoughts on this news
and if you think it will happen or not
comment below and let me know and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
my fan theory video on how old Steve
Rogers was a piggy caused funeral and
Captain America's Civil War which would
be linked at the end I'm really sorry if
my voice sounds horrendous in this video
I've got tonsillitis the thing so I'm
sorry if I'm not my usual chirpy self
but yeah please send your prayers and
wishes because my throat is color right
now so thank you if you manage to sit
through this entire video this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]